[Music]
in other words the ideology at the left
has become narrow even while its
membership in organizations has become
wider I couldn't disagree with you more
I'm so super and I couldn't disagree
without you know Anna talked about the
the the millions of people in Britain
who feel alienated from the political
process who've lost confidence in in
politics who feel left behind well the
truth is they have been left behind by
governments of all colors of all parties
that have pursued the same ideology you
know that started with Thatcher it was
the the the ideology of FATA and Reagan
the ideology of Friedman and Hayek that
we now call me a liberalism that all but
destroyed our industry but impoverished
our people that what public services
connect to its means you know and has
been a disaster and there was a
consensus and Pete when people said on
the doorstep I'm afraid and I've heard
it many times over the last 40 years
you're all the same it was because there
actually was a consensus about austerity
and nobody was allowed to debate it we
weren't allowed to debate it in the
Labor Party and when Jeremy Corbyn got
onto the ballot paper in that leadership
election into the Labor Party for the
first time in the Labor Party there was
a proper debate about austerity and
within weeks actually Theresa May
started parking her tanks on on on our
lawn as though they didn't know they
didn't have much firepower and so you
know it seems to me that is what has
happened and and you know actually
jeremy corbyn's
arrival has opened up political debate
about the future and austerity is not a
necessity it didn't even work on its own
terms austerity is a choice not a
necessity
it's a done
yep before before we come to a clip
Michael Howard in in two seconds just to
pick up
Anna's very last point and throw it to
throw it to you does Jeremy Corbyn
welcome a free and open debate about
brexit which might include for instance
changing his own we are having a debate
about brexit and as Donna said yes is an
as Anna said it is a very very divisive
debate and lots of people want to
exploit that division and Jeremy Corbyn
wants to you reunite the British people
and I actually think look brexit is an
important debate and I voted remain and
I would prefer to see a remain outcome
but actually I don't think it is the
most important issue facing the Britain
Britain I think the most important issue
facing Britain is the failure of Archon
our economy you know we have now had
people seeing their incomes fall for
more than a decade most people many
hundreds of millions of people in this
country have seen their real incomes
fall you know even middle-class kids
leave universities with the equivalent
of a mortgage and they have no hope of
buying a house or even renting one at an
affordable rent and so you know and we
have the more the most unequal society
that we have had for decades for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at AI TV
you